tarn sur les lieux d'intervention rapide
mais on s'en aille chez p as la vidéo du
paramédics tommy st-hilaire a été vu
plus de 500 mille fois depuis une
semaine
son message est simple mais efficace la
campagne à cause du ministre barrette a
été lancée par un syndicats de
paramédics qu'il énonce les conditions
de travail de ses membres
le mot d'ordre adressez vous directement
au ministre de la santé
on a des styles mais cette campagne sur
pied pour justement provoqué le loup
dans sa tanière pour qui il vient de
répondre à nos questions à cause de bord
des dizaines de syndiqués ont répondu à
l'appel et leur cri du coeur ont été
vues plus d'un million de fois sur 20
est ce que c'est normal que plusieurs
fois barjots et plus aucune ambulance de
disponible dans la capitale nationale
l'intention était de sensibiliser les
jeunes à notre problématique donc le
manque de ressources sur le terrain la
campagne circule uniquement sur les
médias sociaux aujourd'hui en 2018 sera
mal immédiat sûr que sont la porte
d'entrée des informations donc on a
décidé personnellement avec les
paramédics de faire cette campagne à
cause de beurre salé vraiment une bonne
influence sur la population
on vous demande pour une prime pour
porter une veste ou pour ne pas arriver
en retard au travail pour une fois c'est
pas un dirigeant syndical qui dit à ses
membres quoi faire on va le laisser la
parole et c'est les mangues qui nous
racontent leur quotidien
c'est la dynamique inverse c'est le
membership qui s'adresse finalement au
ministre est-ce que cette stratégie
médiatique a été efficace donc le
syndicat a obtenu sa première rencontre
avec le ministre aujourd'hui même après
deux mois d'attenté
il est en barrettes connaissait très
bien la campagne alors j'ai un message
envoyé à tous ceux qui veulent faire la
police et si vous avez c'est la pression
ou fait peur choisissez pas la santé est
un peu personne ne connaissait pas
vraiment lu et apprécié certains vidéo
je trouvais très créatif ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal